طبعا هنا شهدت بعض التاخيرات وبعض النقص
لكن
[موسيقى]
النضال المستميت والكفاح المستميت الذي
بذلته بلادنا بشعبها ودولتها لا يمكن لاحد
ان ينكره اذ هو واضح لكل ذي عيان
وطوال فتره
الزلزال وفتره
الكارثه شهدنا مره اخرى كيف ان شعبنا هو
شعب عزيز متاخر متضامن
بهذا الشعب المتضامن
[موسيقى]
هذا الشعب البذول سيتجاوز هذه الازمه
وباذن الله بهذا الشعب بشعب هكذا
سنتجاوز واؤمن جازما الناس سنتجاوز كل
كارثه ولا يمكنني كارثه لا نتجاوزها بهذا
الشعب
اعتبارا من يوم الخميس انتهينا من اعمال
البحث وانقاذ في
اعمال رفع الانقراض والاعمال الاخرى
سننهيها في اقرب فتره ممكنه ونبدا اعمال
الانشاء واعاده احياء هذه المناطق
المنكوبه سابقا في ظن والى وملاطيا شهدت
زلازل وايضا في الثمن
شهدنا السيولا كما شهينا في انطاليا
حرائق
هذه المناطق المنكوبه جميعكم
شهد كيف اننا احيينا هذه المنطقه بعد هذه
الكوارث ومثل ما قمنا بذلك واحنا هذه
المناطق ان شاء الله سنضمن الجراحات هذه
المناطق المنكوبه في زلزال الاخير ان شاء
الله كما قمنا بالخطوات ونقوم بالخطوات
الذي التي تخفف من اثر هذا الزلزال ونقوم
بها بهذه الخطوات اولا باول
المواطنين الذين فقدوا منازلهم وباتت
منازلهم في وضع لا يصلح السكن وفرنا لهم
ونوفره امكانيات السكن في المحافظات نفسها
والمحافظات المجاوره ايضا وفي هذا الاطار
فالفنادق والسكنات الطلابيه الموجوده في
جميع انحاء محافظاتنا
خصصنا اماكن
لاولئك المنكوبين فقط التابع ضمن المؤسسات
المنشات التابعه لوزاره التربيه والتعليم
وفرنا ايواء ل 460 الف مواطن
كما انه في
اماكن الاقامه المؤقته يوجد مليون ومئه
الف شخص ياوي هناك
كما انه وبشكل يغطي كل اصحاب المنازل
واصحاب البيوت المستاجره
شكلنا برنامجا للدعم بالايجاري يتراوح
يغطي المساحه بين الاسعار بين
500 5000 ليره كما
قرارا
سنمنح بناء عليه خمسه عشر الف ليره
للعائلات المنكوبه
كما نتخذ كل التدابير التي تعين مواطنين
على
تضميد جراحهم
ونسعى في هذه الايام الصعبه لان لا نتمكن
مواطنين وحدهم ونقوم بكل اللازم لكي
نؤويهم ونسد كل احتياجاتهم ونقوم باللازم
وسنقوم بكل ما يلزم في هذا الاطار
بعض
المحافظات سنحيها من جديد
سنعاود ان شاء المشاريع هذه المرحله التي
تشمل اعاده انشاء مئه الف وحده سكنيه نؤمن
جازمين باننا سينجح في هذه المرحله اطلب
منكم سنه واحده باذن الله خلال عام واحد
سنقوم بانشاء هذه الوحده السكنيه وسنحييها
بسكانها مره اخرى
وهذا وكما كان في كل مرحله من مراحل تاريخ
سنقضي هذه المرحله ضمن تعاون وتضامن كامل
[موسيقى]
والمناطق المنكوبه ضمن هذه الاطارات
والحالات الطارئه
قمنا بوضع كل الاليات اللازمه
لاعاده الحياه الى امورها الطبيعيه
وكما مددنا عطله التربيه والتعليم الى
تاريخ 20 في كل محافظات التركيه وايضا في
المدارس التي هي موجوده في المناطق
المنكوبه
لن يطلب دوام الزامي من طلاب المدارس في
المناطق المنكوبه
وايضا ارسل العائلات الذين يرغبون في نقل
اولادهم الى مدارس اخرى في محافظات توفر
لهم التسهيلات اللازمه وايضا للعاملين
والتجار وكل قطاعات الشعب نقوم بخطوات
مماثله لتوفير تسهيلات اللازمه
كما نواصل علاج وحمايه الاطفال الذين تم
انقاذهم دون عائلاتهم ونواصل الاعمال في
هذا الاطار كما نقلنا مرضانا
والجرحى
[موسيقى]
جويا وبريا وبحريا وستتم متابعه علاجاتهم
ومعالجتهم عن كثب
كما اننا
[موسيقى]
بالخطوات اللازمه لاولئك الذين يقومون
باعمال النهب
وكذلك من يرفعون الاسعار ويغالون فيها وقد
اصدرنا التعليمات اللازمه لوزاره التجاره
وغيرها في هذا الاطلاق كما اننا نقوم
بخطوه
التدابير اللازمه لمن يتداولون المعلومات
المغلوطه وحملات التشويه والتحريض على
وسائل التشا التواصل الاجتماعي
ولن نتسامح ولا نكون متسامحين معهم نحن
كشعب وكدوله كما تجاوزنا العديد من
الكوارث والنكبات ان شاء الله سنخرج من
هذا من هذه الكارثه ايضا
جبيننا وضاح لامع
خلال المرحله السابقه
[موسيقى]
والتسبيحات وذكر الله
ندفن شهدائنا وثم
سنواصل الانتقال الى مشاجع الاحياء
والانجاء والانشاء نحن امه وشعب يؤمن بان
بان مع كل عسر يسرا
ليست لدي
ادنى ريبه في انها سنتجاوز هذه الكارثه
اسال الله العون واحييكم مره اخرى ومرارا
دمتم في امان الله